A couple of quick announcements before
we start class.
Next Thursday will be our last class and
we will do the final examination
next Thursday. It'll be the same format
as the midterm examination where you can
prepare some questions and we will
review what we learned so far in class.
Um if you are on YouTube and you want to
ask some questions, please leave the
question behind um in the comment
section and my wife will go over and
select
some questions for us to do next
Thursday. Next Tuesday we will do an
overview of everything we've learned so
far and make some predictions about the
next 5 to 10 years, okay? So next week
will be our last week.
Um today I want to talk about Putin in
Beijing. So he came to Beijing um
Tuesday evening. He had a full day
yesterday and he then he left last
night.
And
um as you can see
President Putin and President Xi are
very good friends. They went to a
concert hall where they unveiled a photo
of the two being very close.
Um this is President Putin's 25th visit
to China
and in November he's coming back to
Shenzhen to attend APEC and that'll be
his 26th. He's a very good friend of
China's and the two are very close. This
is the two of them at an education
conference
announcing a year of education exchange
between Russia and China and the goal is
to enhance people-to-people
um connections between China and Russia.
The major
um
output of the meeting was
their different perspectives
on the multipolar world, okay? So, um
this is a part of President Xi's speech,
and this is a part of Putin uh President
Putin's speech. And this is um this is
actually AI translation, so the
translation translation is very bad. But
I will point out certain things, okay?
So, both are committed to
a multipolar world.
And what uh President Xi and President
Putin both want are more exchange, okay?
Bilateral student exchanges,
uh deepen interactions in universities,
do more research together.
He also is afraid of the turbulence in
the world, and he's very much afraid of
a return to the law of the jungle where
might is right. So, it's very important
for the world to work together
in order to maintain the rules-based
international
uh order.
And what President Xi says is that as
permanent members of the UN Security
Council, China and Russia will work
together
to uphold the authority of the UN
international justice, and oppose all
manifestations of unilateralism and
hegemony,
um resurrecting signs of fascism and
militarism, okay?
And
this specifically refers to Germany and
Japan.
Okay?
So, he sees
um the possibility of nationalism, a
resurgence of nationalism in Japan, as a
threat to the peace in East Asia and to
the world in general. Okay, so China is
most resolute resolutely opposed to the
re-re-militarization
of
Japan.
Putin says the same thing, same things
almost, but the tone is very different,
okay? So, um
first of all, Putin is much actually
more specific
than President Xi about areas of
cooperation, okay? So, for example, uh
the 10th Russia
China Summer Games
and also cooperation in between
different media outlets.
Um
and he also talks about how it's
important
to
maintain independent autonomous foreign
policies, yet at the same time work
together
to stabilize the global um
stage. Working together for peace and
universal prosperity, this is a logic
behind Moscow and Beijing's joint
defense of international law and the
provisions of the UN Charter in their
entirety, comprehensive and
interrelationship, okay? So, it sounds
like they're saying thing, but again the
emphasis is different. Whereas in China,
China's very
very much focused on maintaining the
status quo, a world space national
order, putting the UN at the very top,
and for the UN
China and Russia will work towards
um ensuring global stability.
For President Putin, what's important is
that China and Russia take the lead in
leading the multipolar world.
Okay, so these are two very different
conceptions
of how the world should be run, where
the China the Chinese system is let's
just maintain the way things are and
we'll play a supportive role.
Whereas
Putin is like, no, Russia and China
should be the leaders of this new
multipolar world. China can be the
leader and we'll be a junior partner,
but we needed to take the initiative in
promoting global stability." Okay? Um
this is much more clear, okay? Where
this is actually a joint statement
between [clears throat] Russia and China
where they advocate
a multipolar world and Russia and China
undertake and call on the international
community to adhere to the following
basic principles in the relations with
one another. Number one,
uh
maintaining open trade, okay?
Maintaining
sovereignty of different nations,
maintaining
decision-making through consensus, okay?
Under the United Nations. Maintaining
authority of the UN and respecting the
civilizations of each different
nation-state. So, refusing to prioritize
one civilization over another.
All right, so this is something that
both Russia and China agree to. Now,
this is actually a much better
translation of President Xi's words
about the multipolar world, okay?
So, let's read it together. The world
today is far from tranquil.
Unilateralism
and hegemonism are doing grave harm and
the world faces the danger of sliding
back to the law of the jungle. As
permanent members of the UN Security
Council, China and Russia must firmly
carry out the mission responsibility of
major countries, defending authority of
the nations in international fairness
and justice, oppose all unilateral
bullying and acts that turn the wheel of
history backward, and especially oppose
all provocations that negate that negate
the victorious outcomes of World War II
or that seek to reverse the verdict on
and summon back the spirits of fascism
and militarism, jointly pushing for the
building of a more just and reasonable
global governance system, okay? All
right. So, there's a lot of words, but I
will emphasize certain takeaways.
First of all, what President Xi is
saying is that there were three major
winners of World War II.
The United States,
Russia, and China.
And we must
ensure that these three nations who won
World War II are still in charge, okay?
Okay, this is where it's really
important to understand. First of all,
US, Russia, and China are allies, not
enemies, right? Because right now
everyone will think that China and the
United States are competition to rule
the world, and President Xi says, "No,
that's not true. We're allies because we
won World War II together."
All right?
Second, he sees
the real enemies as those who are trying
to
overturn the World War II order. And
those nations, of course, are Japan,
Germany, and Israel.
And the last thing
he'll point out is that all
unilateralism and hegemonism are bad.
Okay?
If you act by yourself and you declare
war against other nations, that's bad.
So, obviously, the United States
attacking Venezuela is bad.
Obviously, the United States attacking
Iran is bad.
But,
what about Russia attacking Ukraine?
Well, according to this framework, this
is also bad.
Okay?
According to this logic of what he said
specifically, this is also bad.
So, it seems as though China and Russia
are best friends, and they will unify
against the United States together, But,
this statement reveals that actually
things aren't as simple as they seem.
All right?
>> [snorts]
>> Also, what's important for us to
understand
is that yes, there are many areas where
China and Russia can work together,
but the cooperation is not going as
smoothly as one would imagine, okay? So,
let's look at some some examples.
First of all,
the energy cooperation between China and
States, it is booming.
Uh what's happening is that China needs
a lot of energy and resources from
Russia. So, you you would think that
they would build infrastructure as soon
as possible to make this trade
as smooth as possible, right? Especially
with this war going on in the Middle
East blocking China's access to the
Middle East uh energy.
But,
um and the main pillar of this
cooperation is something called the
Power of Siberia 2, okay? As you can
see, it extends all the way from the
north of Russia to Shanghai. It's a huge
project.
And everyone has assumed that at this
meeting the first thing that they would
accomplish is signing an MOU, an
agreement, to build this pipeline. And
they have not done so.
And a lot of it is because
China does not want to become too
dependent on Russia. Because obviously,
if you build this pipeline, then you
must buy a lot of energy from Russia.
And but they want to still negotiate
over the price as well as the volume,
okay?
So, that's one area.
Second area is Iraq.
As you can see, the Russians are
absolutely supportive of the Iranians,
right? So, what Vladimir Putin says is
"This absolute unprovoked aggression of
US bombing against Iran has no basis and
no justification whatsoever. For our
part, we are making our efforts to
assist the Iranian people." Okay, then
So, this is This was last June,
actually, when America bombed Iran.
Um the Chinese, on the other hand,
are much more nuanced and much more
diplomatic. So, President Xi says,
um
"Israel's military operation against
Iran has caused a sudden escalation of
tensions in the Middle East."
Uh military conflicts are not the
solution to problems.
Okay? So, the Chinese are much more
muted. And this shows us that, whereas
the Russians are much more clear about
their regional alliances,
China does not want to
participate in disputes among different
nations. Okay?
All right.
So,
one area of cooperation
uh between Russia and China is trade
routes, right? So, as we discussed
previously uh in this class, what the
Americans want to do is they want to
block China from
um accessing global trade. And they can
do that by closing off the Strait of
Malacca, okay? There's something called
the Malacca Dilemma, the dilemma for
China, where if the Americans were to
close off the Strait of Malacca,
China Chinese trade would collapse. So,
the solution is for
China to build another route to the
north, called the Northern Sea Route,
with Russia, okay?
But the problem with this is that now
you're completely dependent on the
Russians, cuz you're going through
Russian territory.
Okay? So, it's not in the advantage of
China to say, "You know what? Screw you,
America. We're going to work with the
Russians." They're actually better off
balancing
Russia and China. That way they keep
both of these
routes open. Okay? This is the most
economical. This is the most strategic
way of
um accessing global trade.
Okay.
Um
but the further you look,
there are certain tension points in the
relationship between Russia and China.
First of all, this relationship clearly
favors China, okay? So, this is a map, a
chart of Russian exports to China. And
as you can see, it's mainly just energy,
coal, LNG, crude oil. Okay? That's the
extent of Russia's exports to China. And
what does China export to Russia?
Mainly
vehicles, electronics, machinery.
Okay? So, basically what China does is
it takes Russian resources, converts
them into manufactured goods, machinery,
in its factories, and then
exports it back to Russia. This is a
very bad deal for Russia.
It's a good deal for China, but it's a
bad deal for Russia, okay? So, that's
one point of tension.
Another point of tension
is
the dependence, okay?
So, basically
um
China
and Russia may be best friends, but look
at this, okay?
So,
Russia's share in Chinese imports
is only 5%.
And then
Russia's share in Chinese exports is
only 3%.
So, economically
Russia and China are not that close.
The problem though is that
Russia is heavily dependent on its
relationship with China because all
these economic sanctions imposed on it
by by the West, okay? So, as you can
see, what's happened
after February 2022
when Putin invaded Ukraine and the West
imposed sanctions on Russia, the
relationship
the economic dependence on China has
increased a lot where where in the
beginning of the war
Russia didn't have that much in RMB, but
now the RMB accounts for
over 40%
of Russian imports, okay?
All right.
Another thing is that
Chinese investors aren't that interested
in going to Russia and investing in
Russia. Okay? So,
before the war, this is the war, okay?
This is the war.
Um there was some, okay?
But there weren't that many. And then
actually as you can see after the war,
it dropped precipitously.
Okay, so why and as you can see from
this map, okay, maybe the Chinese are
in
the Russian Far East. And that makes
sense because it's close to China. But
as you can see, the further you go out,
okay?
Here, there's really no real investment.
Chinese aren't that interested in
investing in Russia. Okay, and why is
that? Well,
um there's so different different
reasons. We can speculate, okay? The
first reason, and this this is really
important, is that the Chinese are
respecting Western sanctions on Russia.
If you do business with the Russians,
then the West can choose to debank you,
remove you from the global financial
system. And Chinese investors care more
about the relationship with the West
than they did they did they did than
they care about with Russia, okay?
That's point one. Point two is that
Russia is not that friendly to foreign
investors.
Uh Russia is a very much a closed
system.
Um and it's very hard to do business in
Russia. If you are in the United States
and you put your money in the United
States, you know you'll be
you'll be protected legally and
contractually. If the person screws you
over, you can go sue the person in a
court of law and you can probably win
the case. Whereas in Russia,
well, if you get screwed over, too bad,
okay?
Uh Russia is still very much a mafia um
system.
Then the third reason, and this is
actually something that that is really
problematic, is that
um
Chinese are much more interested in USD
than they are in the ruble.
Okay?
They're much more interested in
accumulating US dollars than they are in
ruble. And this is the central dilemma
of the uh
sorry, of the Russia-China relationship
where yes, you can
get Chinese to go visit Russia, you can
announce a lot of um cooperation, but at
the at the end of the day, Chinese
investors want USD and not ruble, okay?
Here's another um
chart where yes, okay? As you can see,
Chinese are going More and more Chinese
are going to Russia.
Okay?
All right. So, right now you have about
50,000 Chinese
studying in Russia. But, this
does not compare at all to the Americans
where they are when with when when at
when China had enough money to go study
in America starting in 2008, you can see
a huge boom, okay?
Right?
There's maybe 6
uh 60,000 Chinese who are learning
Russian in
China. Well, everyone else is learning
English.
Okay? So, at the end of the day
Chinese people are much more interested
in the West than they are in Russia. So,
in other words
um
you the relationship between Russia and
China seems to be top-down.
Where it's mandated from the government.
But, the relationship between the United
States
and China seems to be bottom-up.
Where
people
are choosing to work with the Americans.
And so, this is not really an equal
relationship. So, what I want what I
want to look at today is why is this the
case? Why is it that the Chinese want to
go to America?
And what can Putin do about it? And what
can Putin do about it, okay? So, these
are the two questions that we're going
to look at. First of all, why is the
relationship like this? Second of all,
what is Putin's strategy of dealing with
this? Okay. All right.
So, to answer this, we need to go back
to World War II. So, this is this is the
end of World War II and America has won
the war, okay?
So, this is the United States, USA.
This is Europe.
And this is
uh East Asia, okay? Japan, basically.
But, also Taiwan and Korea. Okay. All
right. So, um
World War II has ended and the United
States has a problem. It's got all these
factories
that produce tanks,
machine guns, airplanes.
And now the war is over. So, what are
you going to do with these factories?
You can't just
tell everyone to go home and not work,
okay? So, they make a deal with the
Europeans and these Asians. Basically,
the deal is this.
The Europeans will agree
to buy
manufactured goods from the Americans,
television sets, radio, bicycles, cars.
But then the Europeans and the Japanese
are like, "We don't have any money."
And And the Americans are like, "Don't
worry. We'll lend you the money, okay?
Not only will you will we give you the
goods, but we'll lend you the money to
buy the goods."
Okay? And this is um And of course, the
money is the US dollar. So, the US
dollar is basically a contract, right?
And because the Americans are lending US
dollars to the Europeans and the
Japanese and the East Asians, they want
the US dollars to be actually worth
something, right? So, the US dollar is
spec to gold, the gold standard.
Meaning,
the Americans can at any time
force the Japanese and the Europeans
to
give their gold in exchange for the US
dollars. Okay? Does that make sense?
And so, this is a really good deal for
the Americans. And this is what we call
the Bretton Woods system, okay? Bretton
Woods.
1944.
Where the Americans would facilitate
global trade in order to maintain
domestic power
and they would lend other nations the US
dollars to participate in this trade and
US dollars would be backed by gold.
Okay? So, from 1950
to 1970
this was a great deal for America. And
this led to probably the greatest wealth
creation in the world where if you were
just like a
average white American male, you had the
best life possible.
Okay, this led to tremendous prosperity
in America.
But with prosperity comes corruption and
complacency.
Okay? So, what happened was that the
Americans start to work hard, but then
the Europeans and the Japanese like, we
need to work harder because we need to
rebuild ourselves and we need to pay off
this American debt, okay? So, Europe
start to work really hard, the Japanese
work really harder. And then what
happened was that the Europeans and the
Japanese start to make products that
were actually not only cheaper
than the Americans could make, but also
better. Okay? So, then what it start to
happen was that instead of America
lending money [clears throat] to the
Europeans and the Japanese to buy things
from them, they start to borrow money
in order to purchase the European and
Japanese manufactured goods, okay? So,
now this relationship goes backwards.
All right?
Now, USA went from a creditor nation to
a debtor nation.
But not only that, but the Americans
recognized that, "You know what? We can
put as much money as we want, so we can
spend as much money as we want." And so,
the Americans start to start to do
stupid things like start a war in
Vietnam that they could not win. Like
send a man to the moon for no particular
reason. Like start like the Americans
started to spend way too much money. And
by 1970, the entire world recognized
that, you know what? America owes us a
lot of money, but they probably can't
pay it off with gold.
Okay? And in 1971,
Richard Nixon says, you're absolutely
right, okay?
We can't pay you off with gold, so we're
going to move off the gold standard.
Okay? So this creates a problem now
because everyone's sitting on this US
dollar
and it's actually worth nothing.
So to solve this problem, what Nixon did
was he brought in
to the system,
okay? The GCC,
the Saudi Arabia basically,
uh as well as China
to create more demand for the US for the
US dollar. Okay? So this created the
petrodollar.
Because from now on, Saudi Arabia
would only sell its oil in US dollars.
Okay? And so this kept the system going.
The thing to appreciate about this is
the Americans did this not because it
was strategic, not because it showed
long-term thinking, but because the
Americans by now have become addicted
to the US dollar. Do you understand this
idea? This is really important for you
guys to understand. At this point in
history,
the US dollar
was the global reserve currency.
The global reserve currency is unique in
human history. We've never had the idea
of a global reserve currency where one
currency could be
the basis for value of all other
currencies.
Okay? Never has this happened before.
Why did it happen? Because of an
accident of World War II, when Americans
won and could impose their system on
everyone else.
Okay? And before it was tied to gold,
and they went off the gold standard. So,
this is a complete accident of history.
And it's terrible for America for many
reasons, okay? The first reason is that
it's the guarantor
of global trade.
What does that mean? That to be the
guarantor of global trade. Well, first
of all, it means you have to print a lot
of US dollars, okay?
Excess liquidity.
Okay? You have to print a lot of US
dollars, so people can use US dollars.
And this causes inflation in your
system.
And it's hard to manage, okay?
Second problem is something called an
open capital account.
What does an open open capital account
mean? Means it means like I can change
US dollar anytime I want. So, money can
come in the country, but it can also
flee the country.
Okay? And that's really problematic if
you're trying to control a nation's
currency.
All right?
The third thing
is financialization.
Where, because there's so much demand
for US dollars, because US dollars are
so complex to manage, your economy
shifts from manufacturing to
financialization. Financialization just
means gambling, okay? So, this has been
terrible for America, the American
economy.
The problem is that once you have easy
money, it becomes addictive.
Okay? And so, the way the way to protect
this system is
expansion
war.
You don't care if expanding your system
makes any sense. You don't care if
expanding system is good for your
nation. All you want to do is expand it
in order to create more demand for your
dollar because you're so addicted to it,
okay?
And if you have to, you will fight wars
in order to protect the US dollar,
right? So, this is what leads us to
China.
So, to create China, what what America
did was destroy its middle class and
transfer its manufacturing sector to
China.
It It gave China technology,
capital,
as well as market access.
Okay? And the entire intention was to
create more demand for the US dollar.
Okay?
And this also explains the war in in
Iran
where
Iran is not part of the system
and so America wants to destroy Iran in
order to make everyone else more
dependent on the system, okay? All
right.
Now,
why did China agree to take to to
participate in the system?
Because the US dollar solved for China a
huge a huge problem, okay? Huge problem
is this, the US dollar, I I need you
guys to appreciate this, it monetized
power.
Okay? So, I'm an elite in China and I
control millions of people, but so what?
Who cares?
What the US dollar did was it enabled me
to monetize my power. Meaning now that I
could take this power and store its
value in the US dollar and then export
it to the United States where it would
be safe. Does that make sense to you
guys?
Okay?
This is what it did.
It monetized power in China.
Now the elite
could use
their power over the people and get rich
in America.
Okay?
So in other words,
there were two major beneficiaries
of this system
that was created. Even though this isn't
really make any sense. The first of
course is the American elite, American
American financial elite. The second is
the Chinese political elite.
Okay?
And this explains why it's so hard for
Putin and for Russia
to form an alliance with
China.
Because the elite, the mentality is
to use their power and monetize it
through the US dollar. So what matters
is the US dollar, not
relationship with Russia, okay?
Doesn't make sense. Any questions so
far?
Yeah?
Um so I I think like it also aligns with
the
like the international education of
Chinese which the rich people and the
elites that they send their kids to
America but not the Russia. Yeah, that's
exactly right, okay? So if you think
about it, the entire
point of society in China right now
is to is to generate as much US dollars
as possible, okay? So sending a child to
the United States in order to learn
English, in order to get the American
degree, in order to acclimatize to
American society is part of the
strategy.
Okay? Do you do you understand? Because
RMB itself has no value.
If you convert RMB into US dollars, that
has value.
Okay? Doesn't make sense. Okay, so that
so that's that that's what explains
the relationship between the United
States and China and why it's so hard
for Russia to break into this
relationship. There's There's actually
nothing that Russia can offer the
Chinese elite.
All right?
Okay.
Uh in fact, the Chinese elite think
Russia is a problem because because of
its
uh
it because of its militarism throughout
the world. All right? So, Putin's So,
Putin, if he wants to establish a new
world order, what he needs to do do is
only destroy
the US dollar
as the global reserve currency.
Okay? That is his mission. That is his
game.
If he really wants to destroy the
American empire, he needs to destroy the
value of the US dollar.
Okay?
And the way the way he does that is by
destroying demand for the US dollar.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right? So, we're going to go over
Putin's game, his grand plan to destroy
the US dollar.
Okay. Actually, before I do that,
one thing that I need to make clear to
you guys is that
not all Americans think this is a good
thing, that the United States has the
world reserve currency. In fact, most
Americans, if you explain the system to
them, they'll be like, "Yeah, we don't
want to be the world reserve currency
because one, it causes corruption. It
It causes all these corrupt people to
come to our country. It causes all these
illegal immigrants to come to our
country. It causes us to go fight wars
in Iran.
It causes us to support Israel. So,
yeah, we don't want to be the world
reserve currency."
The problem though is that they're
addicted to it because it's such easy
money, okay? So, this is a
contradiction.
On one hand, Americans know that the
world reserve currency is bad for them,
but on the other hand, they're addicted
to it, okay? So, America's basically
like a drug addict. And so, what do you
do? Well, the only thing you can do is
something called a force
withdrawal, okay?
A force withdrawal.
Which means that you just deny America's
capacity to print money, okay? And And
the way you do that is by destroying
global demand for the US dollar.
I mean, does that make sense? This This
will cause a lot of pain in America in
the short term, basically economic
depression, civil war. In the long term,
this may be the only solution to save
America, okay?
All right.
So, let's go over Putin's grand strategy
for
um
um destroying the US dollar. I will also
point out that
of all the world leaders in the world,
I would say only Vladimir Putin seems to
be strategic, okay? The guy actually is
able to think long term and execute with
perfect timing.
He's He's He's a chess player, okay? And
he's really the only world leader that's
able to think so far ahead and plan so
strategically.
So, um
let's go over his strategy. Basically,
his strategy is very simple.
There are lots of different nations
that
have been sanctioned by the Americans.
How can I form a relationship with these
nation states in order to create
volatility in the world to destabilize
global trade, and therefore destabilize
the US dollar, okay? Also, there are
some nation states that participate in
the system, but who are not happy about
the system. So, how can I actually break
them away from um dependence on America.
All right? So, these are nations that
have been sanctioned by the Americans,
including Russia,
uh Iran,
okay?
Uh North Korea,
Venezuela, Syria,
Belarus, Myanmar, okay? So, Myanmar is
in a civil war, forget about them.
Venezuela has been conquered by the
Americans, Syria is destroyed, okay? So,
basically there are four countries left,
Russia, Belarus, Iran, North Korea. So,
these four are going to work together in
order to destabilize
the global order in order to destroy the
American empire, okay?
All right.
So, the key is Iran and North Korea,
okay? We've already talked a lot about
Iran, so So, today I want to talk more
about North Korea.
So, um
right now,
Russia and North Korea have become very,
very close. So, last year,
I'm sorry, sorry, uh this is actually 2
years ago. June uh 2024, Putin visited
North Korea and signed a mutual defense
pact with North North Korea. This is a
very, very big deal, because what a
mutual defense pact means is that in the
case that North Korea is attacked,
Russia must militarily come to the
defense of North Korea.
If Russia is attacked, North Korea must
come to the defense of Russia.
Okay? This is a big deal because
previously,
North Korea had had a mutual defense
pact with China, signed in 1961
after the Korean War.
And so, you would think that
North Korea doesn't really need Russia
because North Korea already has China to
protect it. So, why is Vladimir Putin
signing a mutual defense pact with um
Kim Jong-un?
This is very strange.
Okay? Well, I think if we wait a couple
of years, we'll know the answer.
All right. Another thing to keep in mind
is that
um
Kim Jong-un has been very supportive of
Russia's war in Ukraine. In fact, he
sent 10,000 troops
to
uh Ukraine. And the thing about the
North Koreans is that at first, they're
not very well trained. They're not very
disciplined.
But the thing about the North Koreans is
they fight to the end, okay?
They have a policy of not surrendering
to the enemy. If you do surrender to the
surrender to the enemy, guess what
happens to your family back in North
Korea?
Okay? So, the thing about the North
Koreans remember is that yes, they're
poor, they're not
technologically sophisticated, but their
soldiers are willing to fight to the
bitter end. And that's actually the key
to winning a war.
All right.
So,
um everyone makes fun of North Korea,
okay? Because it's a very poor place.
So, if you look if you compare North
Korea to South Korea, um
the GDP per person is only $771, okay?
That's it.
Whereas in North Korea, it's over
33,000.
It's one of the highest in the world.
Look at this map, okay, of a satellite
image of
the Korean Peninsula at night. This is
South Korea.
Okay? This is North Korea.
Pretty big difference, guys.
Huge difference, right?
But in a war,
this place would defeat this place.
Okay?
Why?
Because in this class, what you're
taught is game theory.
And if you look at how wars are fought
and who wins wars?
Societies that win wars have three
characteristics, okay? They have energy,
they're open,
and they have cohesion.
Now, what's important for us to
understand is that the poorer you are,
the more likely you are to be energetic,
open, and cohesive.
Okay?
And you're like, "That's
South Korea is wealthy, and has
technology.
It has a lot of weaponry. It has
American support." The problem with
um Western capitalistic societies is
that they tend to be very
individualistic.
As well as complacent
and unequal.
Okay? You can tell because of the birth
rate, right? Where in North Korea, the
fertility rate is still 1.81. It's not
great,
but look at South Korea, 0.81.
Okay? So, in 50 years' time, South Korea
will
lose 80% of its people.
North Korea will also lose people, but
just if there's no war, if we just keep
on going, eventually South Korea will go
to zero, and North Korea will still be
around, okay?
But the other difference
is that when you're poor, you're not
afraid to die,
right?
You have nothing to lose. Whereas, if
you're rich,
well, you're you want to live, okay? So,
all North Korea has to do is basically
say,
"You know what? We have artillery."
And this is Seoul, okay? You can see how
close Seoul is to the border. So, all
North Korea has to do is tell the
Koreans, "You either pay us a lot of
money or we'll go attack you."
Right? It's that simple. And the And the
South Koreans will be like, "We'll give
you money. Just please don't attack us."
And what what this is going to do is
create a lot of tension in Southeast
Asia. It's It's going to happen between
it and Japan, as well. As well as the
United States.
Okay? So, now Putin's defense pact with
North Korea makes a lot of sense.
Because if North Korea just creates a
problem
in the Korean Peninsula,
this is going to be a huge problem for
Japan and the United States. And
remember, the United States is already
distracted in Iraq. It doesn't have the
forces in order to defend South Korea.
Okay?
This This is going to create a lot of
instability.
All right. Let's move on.
Germany, guys. Okay.
So,
um
after Russia invaded Ukraine,
Europe and the United States responded
by imposing sanctions on Russia.
The problem is that Germany was
dependent on cheap Russian energy to
fuel its economy.
And because you lost this Russian
energy,
you have no choice now but to buy
American LNG at 50% more uh 50% markup,
okay? You can tell from this chart the
impact on Europe's economy, where, okay,
um in 2019, they weren't buying that
much from the Americans. But by
2025, they're buying a lot
from the Americans. And again, this is
50% more than Russian LNG.
This has been terrible for especially
the German economy, okay? So,
um this is
the red the dark red is are the Germans,
okay?
And as you can see, the decline has been
pretty steep. Far more steep steeper
than the um French, the Italians, the
Spanish, and the British.
So, the Germans are really hurting
from this war.
Okay? All right.
The other thing is that there's been a
lot immigration
to
um Europe.
Okay? So, in certain places
of Europe, especially uh Scandinavia,
the population of immigrants has gone as
high as 20%, okay?
I in Sweden.
Uh Germany is also a lot under a lot of
stress. So, there's two there's two
these two trends, okay? More immigrants
coming to Europe, which is threatening
the local identity, as well as this war
in Ukraine.
So, these So, AfD
Okay, AfD
uh which
opposes immigration and which opposes
war in Ukraine, they've seen a surge in
popularity.
Okay? And honestly, if there were fair
elections in Germany,
at one point the AfD is going to win.
Okay?
So,
what this means is that the Germans are
choosing instead
to
fight a war. Okay? So, in 2016, you can
see the German military expenditure
wasn't that great, but now they're going
to invest a lot more in the military.
Why? Because their plan is by 2029
for the Germans to have troops in
Ukraine.
Europe is moving towards total war,
okay? Structuring their entire society
for war against Russia.
Russia, everyone says that Russia is now
under a lot of economic pressure, okay?
And it's true that the Russians have in
fact spent a great deal more money
on the military, okay? So, you can see
how after the war started, you have this
huge bump
um in military spending in the Russian
Federation. But the thing to keep in
mind is that it's still pretty low as
part of its GDP, okay? So, the green is
Saudi Arabia.
Uh so, this Saudi Arabia spends
over 10% of its GDP on the military.
The
Chinese spend about 2 to 3%.
Okay? The United States spends
5 to 4%.
The Russians spend about the same, okay?
So, in other words, the Russians have a
long way to go. In fact, Putin still
maintains that the war in Ukraine is a
special military operation. It's not a
full-scale war. If the moment that Putin
declares war, the entire economy shifts
to total war. We we can expect a a
complete surge in
um spending on the military, okay?
Russia hasn't reached Russia hasn't
reached that point yet.
Now,
um
what is Russia's plan for Europe? Europe
Russia Putin doesn't actually want to
fight Europe
um because it would be disastrous for
both Russia and for Europe. But he
understands that there's a civil war
brewing in Europe where these right-wing
parties like the AFD, they're surging in
in the
popularity because they oppose war and
because they oppose immigrants. So, all
Putin has to do is force Germany into a
war and drag this war out, create a war
of attrition. Why? Because as this war
drags on, it's going to create a lot of
global tension back at home, especially
if you're drafting young men to fight
this war, okay? And if that were to
happen, eventually
uh right-wing political parties like the
AFD would come into power.
And how does Putin know this? Because
this has this has historically been
true. This this is what happened in
Russia during World War I
when the Bolsheviks came into power. It
almost happened in Germany, okay, when
communists almost came into power in
Germany. All right? So, war creates
political tensions. And the the longer
the war drags on, uh the more the
greater the tension is, okay? So,
basically what Putin wants to do is
create a civil war in Europe, allow
these right-wing, pro-Russia parties to
come into power, and then
form an alliance between Europe,
Germany, and Russia.
Okay?
So, um part one of the plan is to create
as much political tension in Southeast
Asia as possible by using North Korea.
Part two of this plan is going to war
with Europe in order to destabilize
Europe politically
and allow these right-wing parties to
come into power and then form an
alliance with them, okay?
All right.
Now, let's go on
to the global south.
Okay.
So, the thing about the global south
is [music]
that
Russia has been very supportive of the
global south, especially countries in
Africa. Okay?
Um
After war started when Russia invaded
Ukraine, support
um
for Putin in the global south increased
dramatically
as this map tells you, okay? Now, the
question is
wait a minute here. Russia invaded
Ukraine, so why would people around the
world support Russia?
And the answer is because of narrative,
okay? From a western perspective
Ukraine is an innocent country and
Russia is the aggressor, so clearly
Russia is in the wrong.
But if you are not part of the west, if
you're part of the south, what you will
appreciate is that the west is this
imperial bully and Russia is standing up
for herself.
Okay? NATO NATO was expanding too far,
uh Ukraine was being co-opted by the
west, and so Russia was trying to defend
itself.
And thank God that Putin and Russia and
Russia now can stand up against the
Americans.
Okay? Because we in the south have been
bullied by the Americans all this time.
So, the support for the Russians are
particularly high in Africa, which has
been subject to western imperialism for
the past 20 years. Okay? So, this is a
level of cooperation
uh between Russia and African countries.
As you can see, there is a lot of trade
going on,
but at the same time there's also
military cooperation. There's nuclear
power plant construction. There's also
oil exploration and nickel
uh nickel production. Also, there are a
lot of Russian mercenaries. Russian
mercenaries in Africa.
Okay? And they're usually fighting
against US-backed groups
in order to control the continent.
Um China is also heavily active in
Africa. The thing about China is that
it's very much focused on economic
development as opposed to military
intervention.
The Russians use a full spectrum
strategy in Africa. So they're trying to
win hearts and minds. We know that
because the Russians spend a lot effort
on propaganda, okay? So the Russian flag
is where they have they have propaganda
efforts. And as you can see, China is
not that heavily invested in propaganda
in Africa.
All right.
So what Putin is also trying to do is
create a narrative
that Russia is liberating the world from
Western imperialism. And this has
particular
strength in place like Africa, which has
been which has been a victim of
Western imperialism for a long long
time, okay?
All right.
India, okay?
So
India
for the longest time has been neutral.
So what's been happening is that India
and Russia have becoming very very
close. The impetus for their close
relationship is after the war
in Ukraine, Russian oil became
sanctioned. So the way to evade
sanctions was for Russia sell its oil to
India, which would then sell its oil
around the world. Okay? So what what
we'll see is a very strong relationship
between Russia and India develop over
next few years. What Russia wants from
India are laborers.
Why? Because
uh because of this war Russia is now
short of manpower. So, it needs people
to to run its factories. And eventually,
it's going to win this war in Ukraine.
It's going to need people to go build
rebuild uh Ukraine, okay? So, what we
can expect that Russia and India will
become very very close these past these
next 10 to 20 years. Primarily because
Russia wants to invest in the
relationship between
uh Russia and India.
Um
Iran is the key to
Russia creating a new world order. Why?
Because first of all, as you can see
Iran is really the center of global
trade. So, if
um
Russia wants to access Africa, it wants
to access India, it wants to access
Central Asia, Iran is very important
strategically, okay? It's also very easy
for
uh Russia to trade with
Iran because of the Caspian Sea.
Okay?
All right. So, basically
um
Russia understands that Iran is the key
to
uh global trade Russia's global trade
with the world. And that's why the
Americans are actually attacking Iran.
Because by attacking Iran
uh the Americans
can
block
Russia from global trade or at least
destabilize it, okay? That's why one of
the major battle fronts. This is This is
actually probably one of the two major
battle fronts in World War III. The
first is obviously Ukraine, which will
be fought between
Europe and Russia. Second major battle
front will be
uh in Iran fought between
uh, Iran and the United States. This is
also why, by the way,
Israel is so important. Okay?
Israel. Why is it also important?
Because Israel is
the fortress.
Okay? The American fortress
in this area.
It's very
possible that if Putin places cards
right, all these regions will fall into
the Russian sphere of influence.
So, America's
guarantee against Russian influence is
Israel. And that's why the Americans
support Israel so much, because Israel
is key to check it to keeping Russia in
check. Okay? Does that make sense, guys?
All right.
Um,
the the last thing I'll talk about is
Japan.
Okay? So, the grand strategy of the
Americans is to use Japan to balance
China.
The Japanese don't like this idea, okay?
Because for the longest time, the
Japanese have become were were a vassal
to the Americans. And the Japanese made
a lot of sacri- made a lot of sacrifices
to be the vassal state to America, okay?
But now you've created a situation where
Japan has no choice but to remilitarize
and rethink its national priorities. The
war in Iran is forcing
Japan to rethink the global map, okay?
So, this is So, Japan is heavily
dependent on energy energy imports. And
for most of its history most of its
recent history, it was getting its
energy from the Middle East, okay? But
obviously, most of this energy is now
gone. So, now you have two options. You
can either depend on
Russia or the United States. Now, you
would think, well, I always Japan will
just buy all its oil from the United
States. The United States certainly
thinks so, but the last time this
happened
was before World War II.
Okay?
Japan, before World War II, was getting
90% of its oil from the United States.
But, Japan was becoming too powerful,
and so the United States started to
embargo Japan. Then, Japan had no choice
but then to go invade Southeast Asia for
its oil and attack the United States.
Okay, does that make sense? So, Japan
does not want to put in a situation
where it's completely dependent on
Americans for oil, because the last time
this happened, it didn't really work out
well for Japan.
Okay? So, Japan has no choice in this
matter but to, yes, buy American LNG,
but also to try to smooth things over
with Russia
to supply more oil from Russia.
Okay?
The other problem
for the
Japanese is that
for the longest time, they've been
buying US Treasuries, okay? So, you can
see how China
um yes, China's addicted to US dollar,
but they recognize that the Americans
aren't that dependable.
Um they're putting too much money,
they're too much in debt. So, the
Chinese have been selling US dollars, US
Treasuries.
But, the Japanese have been
increasing
um
buying US Treasuries. Why is that?
Why is it that US Treasuries aren't
worth as much money as before, but the
Japanese continue to buy US Treasuries?
And the answer is because
it's almost like a subsidy
or a bribe
to the Americans, okay?
Right? Because the Americans have a lot
of soldiers in Japan.
So, Japan is a colony. And so, what you
do is you bribe your the Americans to
protect you, but also to just
leave you alone, okay? And the way they
do do do this is something called the
yen carry trade.
Okay? And this is the silliest thing
ever, okay? But but let let me explain
to you
let let me explain to you what this is,
okay? So, what the yen carry trade is
this.
Japanese banks
will lend
money to Japanese corporations at 0%.
Okay? Basically free money. So, if
you're a big Japanese corporation and
you want you need money, you just go to
the Japanese bank and they'll give you
money at 0% interest.
What this means is
you can take this money and then go buy
US treasuries.
Okay? US treasuries
at 5%.
And does that make sense?
All right? And so, that that's what's
led to the surge of Japanese buying of
US treasuries. Basically free money.
It's literally free money.
Okay? But the problem is that as you can
imagine, this is causing huge problems
for the Japanese economy. Okay? And as
as the political situation gets worse
and worse, Japan has no choice but to
repatriate
its money back from the United States.
Basically selling US treasuries.
Okay? So, what America needs to do is
basically force these countries like
Japan, China to continually buy US
treasuries. And that's why we have this
war in Iran.
Okay? To really control the world's
energy supply.
And time is running out for America,
okay? The reason why is that as more and
more people sell US dollars,
as more and more as more and more people
refuse to buy US Treasuries,
certain problems arise, okay? First is
the um
debt interest.
So, right now
the debt is at $39 trillion.
Let's assume the interest is 50%. That
means
that the Americans have to pay two two
trillion dollars in interest payment
alone. Does that make sense?
Okay, that's a huge problem.
Second problem is that as people
refuse to buy US Treasuries, you need to
give them a higher interest rate, okay?
So, right now 5% it has moved up to 6%.
This is this this is a disaster for
America.
Okay?
So,
America need to basically act now.
Okay? It needs to move
down
the Treasury rate.
Okay, the way you move down the Treasury
rate is by forcing people to buy US
Treasuries from you.
Okay, so this is a war that's going on
between Russia and and America, between
Putin and Trump, where Putin is trying
to get people to
not buy US Treasuries, and Trump is
trying to force people to buy US
Treasuries.
Okay? And this is a war that's being
fought right now, okay? Any questions
about about what's going on?
Okay.
How will America become or how will
America end if like the world and
America is so addicted to US dollars?
Wait, wait, could you ask ask ask the
question again?
Uh how will America and world war
like how will America be if the world
and America are still addicted to US
dollars?
Because it's an addiction.
Okay? It's
free and easy money.
Yeah, but but
like what will America become like if
this trend continues?
If this trend continues
with this addiction? Yeah. Okay.
All right. So
right now
if this trend continue, okay?
There's some problems that arise, okay?
The first thing is that
America
will print more money.
Okay? So the debt $19 trillion
will continue
to increase.
And then the world's going to think you
can't actually pay this off, right? So
then what happens is that people stop
buying US Treasuries.
Then the interest rate goes up
in order to get people to buy more US
Treasuries. Because if you don't do
that, if people don't buy US Treasuries,
you're going to default.
Okay?
So what does default mean? Okay? Well
um
let let me explain how this system
works. Okay? First So first of all
it's the Federal Reserve that lends
money to the US government.
Okay? So there's
there are different buyers of US
Treasuries, but the Federal Reserve is
the biggest buyer.
All right? So let's just say
you owe it you China has a trillion
dollars
in US treasuries. And the United States
says to China, you know what? We're not
going to pay you back. Screw you guys.
Okay? Does it matter? No, it doesn't
matter. Who cares? Okay? The Federal
Reserve is a different problem.
Why? Because let's just say you owe the
Federal Reserve 10 trillion dollars.
Okay? Where does Where does the money
come from? It comes from
private banks.
Okay?
And who puts their money in the banks?
The people put their money in the banks.
All right? So, in other words,
the American government has borrowed its
money from the American people.
So, the if the American government were
to default on its debt,
American people would lose all the money
in the bank.
And what would you And what would that
happen? And so, what would happen after
that? A revolution would happen, okay?
In other words, it is impossible for the
US government to default
on this debt.
It would create a revolution in America.
The government would collapse.
Does that make sense?
Okay?
So, now you're just forced to
um
get China to buy two trillion two
trillion dollars.
Do you understand? Because you can't
force the Because you Because you cannot
default
the debt
domestically because everyone in America
would lose all their money.
Okay? So, the only thing you can do is
go overseas and force people to buy US
dollars from you.
And you do that through war.
All right? Does that make sense?
Okay?
So, Putin understands that all he has to
do is stop foreign countries from buying
US dollars and America will collapse in
itself because because the economics
doesn't make any more sense.
Okay, it's impossible for you to pay off
that that interest payment.
Okay, so that that's a stark crisis that
America's facing right now.
Okay, any more questions? Yeah, Alan.
So, I'm curious about like even if
Russia really does collapses systems of
current global economies, like what will
be the new position position of
Russia's?
Like what what is the precious commodity
of Russia's that can maybe give give it
the power to maybe lead the world?
Okay.
So, we're assuming that anyone someone
wants to be the new leader. And the
reality is that it's actually stupid to
be the world reserve currency.
It's silly to be the world leader
because now you're just forced to
spend all your resources on defending
your position in the world, okay?
It's like being a high school bully.
Well, being a high school bully sounds
cool, but now you have to go fight
everyone in the school.
Okay, so no one actually wants to be the
world leader. And America doesn't even
want to be the world leader. It's just
stuck being the world leader because of
these historical accidents. It doesn't
make sense.
So, all basically all Russia's trying to
do is it's trying to get rid of the
school bully.
Once you get rid of the school bully,
there's no more bullies, okay? Which
which means I I can do whatever I want
now. More freedom for Russia.
Now, doesn't mean that Russia will be
peaceful. Russia is going to go is going
to exert its power where it can, but it
will have more freedom of of movement.
Okay, it sees America as as its greatest
threat.
And so,
Russia wants to get rid of America.
China's different.
China
appreciates that historically
its neighbors have been very aggressive,
okay? Who are Who are
Who are China's neighbors? The Japanese,
right? The Russians,
the Vietnamese.
They're very aggressive people.
So, if I'm China, I would prefer America
to be the global policeman, to be the
high school bully.
Right?
Cuz
honestly, if America's the high school
bully, someone else is going to be the
bully. And I'd much rather deal with
America than with Russia.
Okay? So, So, that's why the
relationship between Russia and China is
much more
tenuous, much more unstable than people
believe it is.
It is in the mutual benefit of the two
to get along right now, but in the long
term, there's eventually going to be a
divorce.
Because their interests don't actually
converge
to together, okay?
So,
um
Putin's plan is just to be is to remain
good friends with China. He knows that
China, in the long term, is going to
side more with America than with Russia,
but in the short term, Putin can do as
much as he can
to make China his friend. Okay? So, he
needs China to be neutral.
The worst thing that could happen is
that China sees Russia as a threat and
China and the United States got together
to defend the system.
Okay?
Does that
Does that make sense? Mhm. Yeah.
Yeah, but Okay.
Uh a further question is like this the
collapse of economy like systems will
affect the global police
uh positions of America. Because I think
we previously said that this global
economic system basically build on
Americans uh military powers, but even
though this systems collapse
financially, it doesn't mean that the
military power of American decrease.
Then I What Why then the like
the the Russia will get its like
freedoms to move then?
Okay, look, the reality is that
your military comes from your
nation-state, okay?
Your military
comes from your nation-state. Why?
Because it's your nation-state that
provides the weapons, the manufacture of
the weapons, the people
the so to become the soldiers, the
financing.
Okay?
So, let's just say this nation-state is
in revolution
where the people are fighting a war
against the government. The military has
no choice but to retreat and try to
crush this revolution.
Okay, does that make sense?
So, America doesn't have
the
interest in defending the world if its
entire nation is falling apart. That's
just silly. It has to retreat, okay? Uh
okay, and it's possible that America is
so stupid that its military
um stays overseas. But if that were to
happen, then
the military would need would still need
a nation-state, okay?
And so it needs now to move from America
to different nation-states. And I
imagine that if that if that were the
case, the military military would split
off and and form help um support three
other nation-states, which are Japan,
Germany, and Israel.
In other words,
different theaters of the American
military would find a different
nation-state as their host.
Okay? So, the American forces in East
Asia would go and support Japan. In
Europe, they would support Germany. In
the Middle East, they would support
Israel.
All right?
But they need a nation-state as their
host.
Okay?
Clear?
All right. So, next week is the final
examination. So, if you're on YouTube
you're watching YouTube, please post
your questions in the comment section
and my wife my beautiful wife will
select
um
the very best, okay? All right, see you
guys next week.